hello and welcome to continuous
integration tutorial using jenkins
my name is chidanand and i am with the
simply learn team
today let's get started with jenkins
jenkins in my opinion
is one of the most popular continuous
integration servers of recent times
what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for
sun microsystems way back in early or
mid 2000s
has gradually and eventually evolved
into very very powerful and
robust automation servers it has a wide
adoption
since it is released under mit license
and is almost free to use
jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it
by writing all kinds of plugins plugins
is the heart and soul of jenkins
because using plugins one can connect
jenkins to anything and
everything under the sun with that
introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial i will get into some of
the prerequisites
required for installing jenkins post
which i will go ahead and install
jenkins on a windows box there are a few
first time configuration that needs to
be done
and i will be covering those as well so
once i have jenkins installed and
configured properly
i will get into the user administrative
part i create few users
and i will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users
i will also put in some freestyle jobs
freestyle job is nothing but a very very
simple job
and i will also show you the
powerfulness of jenkins by scheduling
this particular job to run
based upon time schedule i will also
connect jenkins with
github github is our source code where
source code repository where i've got
some repositories put up there
so using jenkins i will connect to
github pull up a repository that is
existing on github
onto the jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is pull
from github sending out emails is a very
very important configurations of
jenkins or any other continuous
integration server for that matter
whenever there is any notifications that
has to be sent out as a part of
either a build going bad or built being
good or built being propagated to some
environment and all these scenarios
you would need the contains integration
servers to be sending out notifications
so i will get into a little bit details
of how to configure
jenkins for sending out emails i will
also get into
a scenario where i will have a web
application a maven based
java web application which will be
pulled from a github repository and i
will deploy it
onto a tomcat server the tomcat server
will be locally running on my system
eventually i will get into one other
very very important topic
which is the master slave configuration
it's a very very important and
pretty interesting topic where
distributed builds is achieved using a
master slave configuration so i will
bring up a slave i will connect the
slave with the master
and i will also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally i will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your jenkins so jenkins has got a
lot of useful information set up on it
in terms of the build environments in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very
easily backed up using a plugin so this
is what i'm going to be covering as a
part of this
tutorial jenkins is a web application
that is written in java
and there are various ways in which you
can use and install jenkins
i have listed popular three mechanisms
in which jenkins is usually
installed on in any system the topmost
one is as a windows or
linux based services so if at all you
have windows like the way i have
and i'm going to use this mechanism for
this demo so i would download a msi
installer that is specific to jenkins
and install this service so whenever
installed as a service it goes ahead and
nicely installs all that is required for
my jenkins
and i have a service that can be started
or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of linux as well one other
way of running jenkins is downloading
this generic war file
and as long as you have jdk installed
you can launch this war file
by the command opening up a command
prompt or shell prompt effortless on
linux box
specifying java hyphen jar and the name
of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt
you either do a control c and then bring
down this prompt and your jenkins server
would be down
other older versions of jenkins were run
popularly using this
way in which you already have a java
based web server running
up and running so you kind of drop in
this war file into the root folder or
the httpd root folder of your
web server so jenkins would explode and
kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
administration is all taken care of by
the apache or the tomcat server or the
web server on which jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because
if they don't want to maintain two
servers if they already have a java web
server which it's being
nicely maintained and backed up jenkins
can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're gonna bring up
your jenkins instance the way we're
gonna operate jenkins is
all going to be very very same or
similar one with the subtle changes in
terms of user administration if at all
you're launching it through
any other web server which will take
care of the user administration
otherwise
all the commands or all the
configuration or the way in which i'm
going to
run this demo it is going to be same
across any of these installations
all right so the prerequisites for
running jenkins as i mentioned earlier
jenkins is nothing but a simple web
application that is written in java
so all that it needs is java preferably
jdk 1.7 or 1.8
2gb ram is the recommended ram for
running jenkins and also like any other
open source
tool sets when you install jdk ensure
that you set in the environment variable
java home
to point to the right directory this is
something very
specific to jdk but for any other open
source tools that you've installed
there's always a preferred environment
variable that you got to set in which is
specific to that particular tool that
you're going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other
open source projects because the way
open source projects discover themselves
is using this environment variables
so as a general practice or a good
practice always set these
environment variables accordingly so i
already have jdk 1.8 installed on my
system
but in case you do not what i would
recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
home page and just type in or search for
install jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle home page
you'll have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers
that is okay that you can pick up based
upon the operating system on which
you're running so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system
so i will not get into the details of
downloading this or installing it
let me show you once i install this what
i've done with regard to my path
so if you get into this environment
variables
all right so i have just set in a java
home variable
if you see this colon program files java
jdk 1.8 this is where my
my java is located c
program files c program files
java okay so this is
the home directory of my jdk so that is
what i've been
i've set it up here in my environment
variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that
in case you want to run java or java c
from a command prompt
ensure that you also add that path into
this path variable
so if you see this somewhere i will see
yes there you go
sequel in program files java jdk 1.8 pin
so with these two i'll ensure that my
java
installation is nice and you know good
enough so
to check that to double check that or to
verify that let me just open up a simple
command prompt
and if i type in java iphone version
all right and java c hyphen version
so the compiler is on the path java is
on the path
and if at all i do this
even the environment variable specific
to my java is
installed correctly so i'm good to go
ahead with my
jenkins installation now that i have my
prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions
weeklies i would not recommend that you
try these unless until you have a
real need for that long term support is
good enough and as i mentioned there are
so many flavors of
jenkins that is available for download
all right so what i want is
yes this is the war file which is a
generic war file that i was talking to
you earlier
and this is the windows msi installer so
go ahead and download this msi installer
i already have that downloaded so let me
just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
jenkins instance
or other installer this is a pretty
maybe a few months old but this is good
enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that
there is a variable called jenkins home
this is where jenkins would store
all this configuration data jobs project
workspace and
all that specific to jenkins so by
default if at all you don't set this to
any particular directory
if at all you install an msi installer
all your installation gets into
c colon program files 86 and jenkins
folder
if at all you run a war file depending
upon the user
id with which you're running your war
file the jenkins folder there's a dot
jenkins folder that gets created inside
the
user home directory so in case you have
any need wherein
you want to back up your jenkins or you
want jenkins installations to get into
some specific directories
go ahead and set this jenkins home
variable accordingly before you even
begin your installation for now i don't
need to do any of these things so i've
already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation
all right so this is my jenkins msi
installer i would just
i don't want to make any changes into
the jenkins configuration
c colon program files is good for me
yeah this is where
all my destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this
i don't want to change this i would just
say go ahead and
click installation
okay so what typically happens once the
jenkins installation
gets through is it'll start installing
itself and there are some small checks
that needs to be done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080
so let me just open up localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of
the installation process wherein i need
to type in the hash key
all right so there's a very very simple
hash key that gets stored out here
so i'll have to just copy this path
if i told you you're running as a war
file you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station
so as a part of the installation it just
asks you to do this
so if that is not great it will crib
about it but
this looks good so it's going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation
so you would need to install some
recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other
so it's like the typical rpm kind of a
problem where you try to install some
plugin and it's got a dependency which
is not installed and you get into all
those issues
in order to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended
so just go ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is a whole lot of plugins which
are bare essential plugins that is
required for jenkins
in order to run properly so jenkins as a
part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you
at this moment jenkins needs uh lots of
bandwidth in terms of network
so in case your you know your network is
not so good few of these plugins would
kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on
openly or mirrored sites and sometimes
some of them may be down
so do not worry in case some of these
plugins kind of fail to install
you'll get an option to kind of retry
installing them but just
ensure that you know at least most or
1995 of all these plugins
are installed without any problems let
me pause the video
here for a minute and then get back once
all these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins
so after that i get to create this first
admin user
again this is one important point that
you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it
all right so i'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that i can remember i will
that's my name and um an email id is
kind of optional but it doesn't allow me
to go ahead
in case i don't so i just given an admin
and i got a password i've got i remember
my password
this is my full name all right i say
save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins
installation it was not that tough was
it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly
let me quickly walk you through some
bare minimal configurations that is
required
these are kind of a first time
configuration that is required
so and also let me warn you the ui is
little hard for
many people to wrap their head around it
specifically the windows guys
but if at all you're a java guy you know
how painful it is to write ui
in java you will kind of appreciate you
know all the effort that has gone into
the ui
bottom line you are a little hard to you
know wrap your head around it
but once you start using it possibly
you'll start liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as manage and cans
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all jenkins configuration so i'll get
into some of those important ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of
put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance
few things to kind of look out for this
is a home directory this is a java home
where all the configurations all the
workspace
anything and everything regarding
jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's probably show
up somewhere
up here on the menu number of executors
very very important configuration
this just lets jenkin know at any point
in time
how many jobs or how many threads can be
run you can kind of visualize it like a
thread that can be run
on this particular instance as a thumb
rule if at all
you're on a single core system number of
executors two should be good enough
in case at any point in time there are
multiple jobs
that kind of get triggered the same time
in case the number of executors are less
compared to the number of jobs that have
there to woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually
jenkins will get to running those jobs
just bear in mind that
whenever a new job kind of you know gets
triggered the cpu usage and the memory
usage
in terms of the disk right is very high
on the jenkins instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors 2 for my system is kind of
good
label for my jenkins i don't want any of
these things usage
how do you want to use your jenkins this
is good for me because i only have a
primary
server that is running so i want to use
this note as much as possible
quite pretty each of these options i've
got some
pair minimal help kind of a thing that
is that is out here
by clicking on these question marks you
will get to know as to what are these
particular
configurations all right so this all
look good what i want to show you here
is there's something regarding the
docker
timestamps git plugin svn email
notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails
and what i've done here is i've just
configured the smtp details of my
personal email id
in case you are in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email id that
is set up for jenkins server
so you can specify the smtp server
details of your
company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails
but in case you want to try it out like
me i have configured my personal email
id which is on my gmail
for sending out notifications so the
smtp server would be
smtp.gmail.com i'm using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id
and my password i'm using the smtp port
which is 465
and i'm you know reply to address is the
same as mine i can
just send out an email and see if at
all this configuration works again gmail
would not
allow you to allow anybody to send out
notifications on your behalf
so you'll have to lower the security
level of your gmail id
so that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf
so i've done already that i'm just
trying to see if i can send a test email
with the configuration that i've set in
yes all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your you
know your gmail
account in case you want to do that if
not put in your organization smtp
server details which are for the valid
username and password and it should all
be set
all right so no other configurations
that i'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so i come back to managing
kins okay one other thing that i want
to kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server
it doesn't know what kind of a code base
it's going to pull in
what kind of a tool set that is required
or what is the code that is going to
pull in and how is it going to build
so you would have to put in all the
tools that is required
for building the appropriate kind of
code that you're going to pull in from
you know your source code repositories
so just to give you an example
in case your source code is a java
source code and
assuming that you know because in this
demo this is my laptop and i've put in
all the configurations jdk
everything on my laptop because i'm a
developer i'm working on the laptop
but my continuous integration server
would be you know a separate server
without anything being installed on it
so in case
i want jenkins to you know run a java
code
i would need to install jdk on it i need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here
this way okay since i already have the
jdk installed and i've already put in
the java home
directory or rather the environment
variable correctly i don't need to do it
git if at all i want the jenkins server
to use git
git is a you know command bash or the
command prompt for for
running git and connecting to any other
git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
gradle and maven if at all you have some
mavens as well
you want to do this any other tool that
you're going to install
on your system which is your continuous
integration server you will have to come
in here and configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything manage jenkins let me see what
else is required
yes configure global security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default
it's the security access control is set
to jenkins
own user database so what does this mean
you know
jenkins by default it uses file system
where it stores all the user names which
hashes up these user names
and kind of stores them so as of now it
jenkins is configured to use its own
database
assuming that you are running in an
organization you would probably want to
have a you know some sort of an ad or an
ldap server using which you would want
to
control access to your jenkins
repository rather jenkins tool
so you would specify your ldap server
details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your
ldap or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization
but for now since i don't have any of
these things i'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that
once i put in few jobs so for now let me
not get into any of these
details of this just be aware that
jenkins can be connected for
authorization to an ldap server or you
can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this
stuff that's good for me so enough of
all these configurations
let me put in a very very simple job
all right so job new item you know a
little
difficult to kind of figure out but then
that's the new item so i'll just say
you know first job this is good for me i
just give a name for my job
i would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me
i don't want to choose any of that so
unless until you choose any of this this
particular button would not become
active
so choose the freestyle project and say
okay
at a very high level you would see
general source code management
build triggers build environment build
and post build
in case you install more and more
plugins you will see a lot more options
but for now
this is what you would see so what am i
doing at the moment i'm just putting up
a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so i don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo work let me just put in a very very
simple
job i'll give a description this is an
optional thing this is my
first jenkins job all right
i don't want to choose any of these
again there are some helps
available here i don't want to choose
any of this
i don't want to connect it to any source
code for now
i don't want any triggers for now i'll
come back to this in a while
build the environment i don't want any
build environment as a part of this
build step
you know i just want to you know run few
things so that i kind of
complete this particular job so since
i'm on a windows box i would say
execute windows batch command all right
so what do you want to do i would let me
just echo something echo
hello this is my first
jenkins job and possibly i would want
the date and the time stamp
pertaining to the job i mean the date
and time in which this job was run
all right very very simple command that
says you know this is my first job it
just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me
save this job all right so once i save
this job you know the job names comes up
here
and then i need to build this job and
you will see some buildings tray out
here nothing is there as of now because
i've just put in a job
have not run it yet all right so let me
try to
build it now you see a build number
you will see a date and a timestamp so
if i click on this
you will see a console output if i go
here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into
if you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular jenkins installation
is all here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i've created
whichever i'm running would you know
there will be individual folders
specific to the jobs that has been put
up here all right
so one job one quick run that's what it
looks like
pretty simple okay let me do one thing
let me put up a second job
i would say second job i would say
freestyle project
all right this is my second job i just
want to
demonstrate the powerfulness of the
automation server and how simple it is
to
automate a job that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because
at the core of jenkins is a very very
powerful automation server
all right so what i'm going to do i will
just keep everything else the same
i'm going to put in the build script
pretty much similar to
second job that
gets triggered automatically
every minute all right let me do that
percentage date and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job
and it pretty much does the same thing
as what i was doing earlier in terms of
printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger so a build can
be triggered
using various triggers that is there so
we'll get into this github
triggering or hook or a web hook kind of
a triggering later on but for now what i
want to do i want to ensure that this
job that i'm going to put in
would be automatically triggered on its
own let's say every minute i want this
job to be run
on its own so build periodically is my
setting
if you see here there's a bunch of help
that is available for me
so for those of you who have written
cron jobs on linux boxes you'll find it
very very simple
but for others don't panic let me just
put up a very very simple
regular expression for scheduling this
job every minute
all right so that's one two
three four five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i'm
going to put in
and jenkins got a little worried and
he's asking me
do you really mean every minute oh yeah
i want to do this every minute
let me save this and how do i check
whether it gets triggered every minute
or not
i just don't do anything i'll just wait
for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job in a minutes time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see
it's automatically got trigger
if i go in here yep
second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this jog would be
automatically triggered
now that i have my jenkins up and
running
a few jobs that has been put up here on
my jenkins instance i would need
a way of controlling access to my
jenkins server this is wherein i would
use a plugin called role
based access plugin and create few rules
the rules are something like a global
rule and
a project rule project specific growth i
can have different roles
and i can have users who have signed up
or
the users whom i create kind of assigned
to these roles so that
each of these users fall into some
category this is
my way of kind of controlling access to
my jenkins instance and
ensuring that people don't do something
unwarranted
all right so first things first let me
go ahead and
install a plugin for doing that so i get
into manage jenkins
and manage plugin a little bit of a
confusing screen in my opinion there's
updates available
installed in advance as of now we don't
have the role based plugin so let me go
to
available it'll take some time for it to
get refreshed all right now these are
the available plugins
these are the install plugins all right
so let me come back to available
and i would want to search for my role
based access plugin so i would just
search for role
and hit enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables
user authorization using a role-based
strategy roles can be
defined globally or for particular jobs
or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
right looks good so far yes go back to
the top of the page yes
remember jenkins is running on a java
using a java instance
so typically many things would work the
same way unless and until you want to
restart jenkins once in a while
but as a good practice whenever you do
some sort of a big installations or
big patches on your jenkins instance
just ensure that you kind of restart it
otherwise there would be a difference in
terms of what is installed on the system
and what is there on the file system
you will need to flush out few of those
settings later on but for now these are
all very small plugins so this would run
without any problems but otherwise if at
all there are some plugins
which would need a restart you know
kindly go ahead and restart your jenkins
instance
but for now i don't need that it looks
good i've installed the plugin
so where do we see my plugin i installed
the plugin that is specific to the
user control or the access control so
let me go into yes
global security and i would see this
role-based strategy showing up now all
right so this
comes in because of my installation of
my role-based uh plugin
so this is what i would want to enable
because i already have my own database
setup and for the authorization part
in the sense that who can do what i'm
going to install i mean i've
already installed a role based strategy
uh plugin and i'm going to enable that
strategy
all right i would say save okay now
i've installed the role based access
plugin i would need to just set it up
and check that you know
i would go ahead and create some roles
and ensure that i assign
users as per these roles all right so
let me go to
manage jenkins configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only
after you install these plugins so for
now i've just
enabled the plugin i have enabled
role-based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular
jenkins instance so i would say first
manage rules
so i would need to create some roles
here and the roles
are at a very high level these are
global rules and there are some project
rules
and there are some slave rules i'll not
get into details of all of this
at a very very high level which is a
global role let me just create a
role a role can be kind of visualized
like a group
so i would create a role called
developer typically the jenkins instance
or the ca instance are kind of owned up
or controlled by qa guys
so qr guys would need to provide some
sort of uh
you know limited access to developers so
that's why i'm creating a role
called developer and i'm adding this
role at a global role level so i would
say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there
and each of these options if you hover
over it
you would see some sort of a help on
what what are these
uh you know permissions specific to so
what i want is like you know it sounds a
little
you know different but i would want to
give very very little permissions for
the developer
so from an administration perspective i
would just want him
to have a read um kind of a role
credentials again i would just want to
view kind of a rule
i don't want him to create any agents
and all that stuff that's looks good for
me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly read i don't want him to build
i don't want him to cancel any jobs i
don't want him to configure any job i
don't even want him to create any job
i would just want him to read few things
i would not give him possibly
a role to the workspace as well i mean i
don't want him to have access to the
workspace i would just want him to read
a job
or check you know have read-only access
to the job run
no i don't want him to give him any any
particular access which will allow him
to run any jobs
view configure yeah possibly create
yeah delete i don't want to read yes
definitely and this is the specific role
so what am i doing i'm just creating a
global role called developer
and i'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that i don't want
this developer to be able to run any
agents
nor create jobs or build jobs or cancel
jobs or configure jobs
at the max i just want him to read a job
that is already put up there
okay so i would save now
i created a role i still don't have any
users
that is there on the system so let me go
ahead and create some
user on the system that's not here
how sick configure management's
manage users okay let me create a new
user
i would call this user as yeah
developer1 sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember okay
his name is developer1
at t dot com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one
is a user that i have configured so
still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so
i would go to manage and gains i would
say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular
i will find the particular user and
assign him the developer role
that i have already configured the role
shows up here
i would need to find my user whoever
created
and then assign him to that particular
role so if you remember
the user that i created was developer
one
i would add this particular user and now
this particular user what kind of a role
i want him to
have because this is the global rule
that had created
so developer i would assign this
developer 1 to this particular
global rule and i would go ahead and
save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user
by logging out of my admin account and
logging back
as developer one if you remember
this role was created with very less
privileges
so there you go i have jenkins but i
don't see a new item i can't trigger a
new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that
the maximum i can do is look at the job
see what was there as a part of the
console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qr person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights
so the rights that he set out by
creating a developer
role and anybody who is tagged any user
who's tagged
as a part of this developer role would
get the same kind of permissions
and these permissions can be you know
fine grain it can be a project specific
permissions as well but for now
i just demonstrated the high level
permission that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo
with the developer role that was created
i have very very less privileges
one of the reasons for jenkins being so
popular as i mentioned earlier
is the bunch of plugins that is provided
by users or community users who don't
charge any money for these plugins but
it's got plugins for connecting anything
and everything
so if you can navigate to or if you can
find jenkins plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins
whatever connectors that you would need
if you want to connect jenkins to
an aws instance or you want to connect
jenkins to a docker instance or any of
those
containers you would have a plug-in you
can go and search up if i want to
connect jenkins to bitbucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available
okay so bottom line jenkins without
plugins is nothing so plugins is the
heart of jenkins
for you to connect or for in order to
connect jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got java and maven
you would need to install
maven and jdk on your jenkins instance
if at all you're looking for a
net build or a microsoft build you would
need to have ms build installed on your
on your jenkins instance
and the plugins that will trigger ms
build
if at all you want to listen to some
server side web hooks from
github you will need github specific
plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world
as long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plug-in
that is installed on your jenkins
instance sonarcube is one of the popular
static code analyzers so you can connect
a jenkins build you can build a
job on jenkins and push it to sonar cube
and get sonar
cube to run analysis on that and get
back the results in jenkins
all of these works very well because of
the plugins now with that
let me connect our jenkins instance to
github i
already have very very simple java
repository up on my github
instance so let me connect jenkins to
this particular github instance and
pull out a job that is put up there all
right so this
is my very very simple you know
repository that is there called hello
java
and this is what is there in the repo
there is a hello hello.java
application that is here or a simple
class file that is there
it's got just one line of system dot out
so this
is already present on github.com at this
place and this would be the
url for this uh repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
steepest url
so what i would do is i would connect my
jenkins instance
to go to github provide my credentials
and pull out this repository which is on
the cloudhostedgithub.com
and get it to my jenkins instance and
then build this particular java file
i'm keeping the source code very very
simple it's just a java file
how do i build my java file how do i
compile my java file i just say java c
and the name of my
class file which is hello java and how
do i run my java file
i would say java and hello okay so
remember i don't need to install any
plugins now because what it needs is a
git plugin
so if you remember when we were doing
the installation there was a bunch of
recommended plugins so git
is already installed on my system so i
don't need to install it again
so let me put up a new job here it says
git job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me i would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some
echo kind of uh jobs we did not need any
integration with any of the source code
systems so now let me connect this so
i'm going to put up
a source code and git would show up
because the plugin is already there
svn perforce any of those additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and
jenkins connects wonderfully well to all
these particular
source control tools okay so i would
copy the https url from here
i would say this is the url that i'm
supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password
so i'll have to specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username
and this is my https
credential for my job okay so this is my
username and this is my password
i just save this and say add and then i
would say
you know use this credentials to go to
github
and then on my behalf pull out a
repository
all right if at all at this stage if
there's any error in terms of not able
to
jenkins not able to find git or the git
dot exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that
you know something is not right you can
just go ahead and kind of fix that
for now this looks good for me i'm going
to grab this
url what am i going to do this step
would pull the
source code from the github and then
what would be there as a part of my
build step
because this repository just has a java
file
correct hello.java so in order to for me
to build this i would just say execute
windows batch command
and i would say java c hello dot
java that is the way i would build my
java code and if i have to run it
i would just say java hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after
the repository contents are fetched from
github so java c
java that sounds good i would say save
this
and let me try to run this
okay if you see there's a lot of you
know it executes kit on your behalf it
goes out here it provides my credentials
and says you know it pulls all my
repository and by default it will pull
up the master branch that is there on my
repository and it kind of builds this
whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello
and there you see this is the output
that is there and if at all you want to
look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is my workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there
on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on github repository
all right so this was the same program
that was here and
jenkins on our behalf went over all the
way to github
pulled this repository from there and
then you know it brought it down to my
local system on my jenkins instance
it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that i have integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of
it what i will do is i have a maven
based
web application that is up there as a
repository in my
github so this is the repository that
i'm talking about it's called amv and
web app
it's got it's a maven based repository
as you would know maven is a very very
simple java based build tool that will
allow you to
run various targets and it'll compile it
will based upon the goals that you
specify
it can compile it can run some tests and
it can you can build a
war file and even deploy it into some
other server for now what we're going to
use
maven is just for building and creating
a package
out of this particular web application
it contains a bunch of things
and what is important is just the
index.jsp
it just contains an html file that is
there as a part of this
web application so from a perspective of
requirements
now since i'm going to connect jenkins
with this particular
repository get we already have that set
we only need two other things one is
maven because jenkins will use maven so
in order to use
maven jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
jenkins box
and in this case the jenkins box is this
laptop
and after i have my maven installed i
also need a tomcat server
tomcat is a very very simple web server
that you can freely download
i'll let you know how to quickly uh
download and install the
tomcat all right so download maven
first
and the various ways in which you can
kind of download this maven
there is zip files binary zip files and
rkf files so what i've done is i've just
already downloaded
maven and if you see i've unzipped it
here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven so
as
you know maven again is is one open
source build tool
so you'll have to set in a few
configurations and set up the path
so mvn hyphen iphone version if i
specify this
after i set in my path my one should
work and if at all i echo
m2 home which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to mamma node it is already set here
so once you unzip maven just set this m2
home
variable to the directory where you
unzip your mi1
also just set the path to this
particular directory slash bin
because that is where your maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system
i just verified it okay next one is a
tomcat server
download apache tomcat server
8.5 is what i have on my system so i'm
just going to show you
where to download this from this is
where you download tomcat server
and um i already have the server
downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
i just unzip it here
and it kind of has a bin and
configuration i have made some subtle
changes in the configuration
first and foremost tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080.
since we already have our jenkins server
running on port
8080 we cannot let tomcat run on the
same
port there will be a port clash so what
i've done i have configured tomcat
to use a different port so if i go to
this configuration file here
there is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080
i've just modified it to 8081. so i've
changed the port on which my tomcat
server would run all right so that's one
chain second change when jenkins kind of
tries to get into my tomcat and deploy
something for someone
he would need some authentications so
that he'll be alloyed deployment by
tomcat
so for that i need to create a user on
tomcat and provide this user credentials
to my jenkins instance
so i would go to tomcatusers.xml file
here
i've already created a username called
deployer and the password is deployer
and i've added a role called manager
hyphen script manager hyphen script will
allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there
so using this credentials i will enable
or i'll empower jenkins
to get into my tomcat server and deploy
my application
all right only these two things that is
required let me just start my tomcat
server first
so i get into my bin folder i open a
command prompt here
and there's a startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes
there you go tomcat server is up and
running now this is running on port 8081
so let me just check
if that looks good so localhost
8081.
okay my tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this
that's also fine so what i'll do as a
part of my first job my one is also
installed on my system so i am good to
use maven
as a part of my jenkins so i will put up
a simple job now
i will say job
mbn
web app i'll call this freestyle job
that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the url of my git repository
is this guy https url
okay that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that are
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into all right so now the
change
happens here where after i get this
since i said this is a simple maven
repository
i will have some maven targets to run
so the simple target first is let me run
maven
package this creates a war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever i
run this package it kind of
creates it it builds it it tests it and
then creates a package
so this is all that is required maybe
let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well
if there's any problem with my war file
or the war file gets created properly
okay wonderful so it built a war file
and if you see it all
shows you what is the location where
this war file was
generated so this will be the workspace
if you see this this war file was
successfully built now
i need to grab this particular war file
and then i would need to deploy it into
tomcat server again i would need a small
plugin
to do this because i need to connect
tomcat with my jenkins server
let me go ahead and install the plugin
for the container deployment
so i would go to manage plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need
i will install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay it installed the plugin so if at
all you see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder i would see
this web application war file that is
already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this
war file and deploy it onto the tomcat
server
for deploying onto the tomcat server i
will use the credentials of the user
that have created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm going to just
create a package that's all fine
now add a post build step
so after the war file is built as a part
of this package
directive let me use this deployment to
container now this will show up after
you install the plugin
so deploy this one to the container now
what is that you're supposed to specify
you're supposed to specify
what is the location okay
so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there
that will allow you to from the root
folder it will pick up the war file that
is there
so star star forward slash star dot war
that's good for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that
you know under which it will get
deployed into the tomcat server i will
just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now i need
to specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
this tomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have
so this would be the url so the
credentials
yes i need to add a credential for this
particular
server so if you remember i had created
a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential i
would say
i would say add a new credential jenkins
credential
the username is deployer and the
password is
deployer
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is find found
in this particular
folder and then you know context path is
same in web use the deployer deployment
credentials
and get into this local host which is
there 8081
this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system
and then go ahead and deploy it okay
so that is all that is required so i
would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it
and looks like the deployment went ahead
perfectly well so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server
there would be a web apps folder you
would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application so the
application was built the source code of
this application was pulled from the
github server
it was built locally on the jenkins
instance
and then it was pushed into a tomcat
server which is running on a different
port which is 808.1 now for this demo
i'm running everything locally on my
system but assuming that you know
this particular tomcat instance was
running on some other server
with some other different ip address all
that you've got to go and change is
the url of the server so this would be
the
server in case you you already have that
uh you know if you have a tomcat which
is running
on some other machine that's all fine
with a different ipa that's all good
enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed
that's the beauty of jenkins and
automatic deployments or other
deployments
using jenkins and maven distributed
build
or master slave configuration in jenkins
as you would have seen you know we just
have one instance of jenkins server up
and running all the time
and also i told you that whenever any
job that kind of you know
gets started on the jenkins server it is
little heavy on
in terms of disk space and the cpu
utilization
so which kind of you know if at all
you're in an organization wherein you're
heavily reliant on
the jenkins server you don't want your
jenkins server to go down
so that's wherein you kind of start
distributing the load that is there on
the jenkins server so you primarily have
a server
which is just a placeholder or like a
master who will take in all the kind of
jobs
and what you'll do is based upon trigger
that has happened to the job or
whichever job needs to be built he
if at all he can delegate these jobs
onto some other machines or some other
slaves
you know that's a wonderful thing to
have okay use case one use case two
assuming that you know if you have a
jenkins server that is running on a
windows box
or on a linux one and if at all you have
a need where you need to build based
upon operating systems you have multiple
build configurations to support
maybe you need to build a windows you
know windows based dot net
kind of a projects where you would need
a windows machine to build this
particular project
you also have a requirement where you
want to build linux linux based
systems you also have a mac you you
support some sort of apps or something
that is built on mac os you would need
to build
you know mac based system as well so how
are you going to support
all these needs so that's where in a
beautiful concept of master slave or
you know primary and delegations or
agent and master comes into play
so typically you would have one jenkins
server who will just you know configure
with all the proper authorizations
users configurations and everything is
set up on this jenkins server
his job is just delegations he will
listen to some sort of triggers or based
upon the job that is coming in
he will if there is a way nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control lot of other systems
and these systems may not have a
complete or there's no need to put in a
complete
jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple
runner or a slave that's a simple jar
file that is run as a low priority
thread
or a process within these systems so
with that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down
your master would know that what went
down and kind of delegate the task to
somebody else
so this is the kind of distributed build
or the master slave configuration so
what i'll do
in this exercise or in this demo is i'll
set up a
simple slave but since i don't have too
many machines to kind of play around
what i'll do is i will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so i've got the c
drive and d drive my jenkins is on my c
drive so what i do is i would just use
my e drive
and set up a very very simple uh slave
out there i'll just show you how to
provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave
let me go back to my jenkins master and
configure him to you know talk to an
agent
so there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what i'm going to choose is something
called as jnlp
java network launch protocol so using
this i would ensure that you know the
client and server talk to each other
so for that i need to ensure that i kind
of enable this jnlp port
so let me try to find out where is that
let me try this
okay yes agents and
by default this jlp agents thing would
be disabled
so if you see here there's a small help
on this so i'm going to use this jnlp
which is nothing but
java network launch protocol and you
know i'll configure
the master and server to talk to each
other using jlp
so for that i need to enable this guy so
i
enable this guy instead of making the by
default the configuration was disabled
so i make him random i make him you know
enabled and i say save this
configuration
all right so now configured or has made
a setting
for the master so that the jlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and
you know create an agent so i'll go to
managed nodes
so if you see here there's only one
master here so let me provision a new
node here
so this is the way you know in which you
bring up a new node you have to
configure it on the server
jenkins would put in some sort of
security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular engine so that
he can connect what jenkins master so i
would say new node
i would give a name for my node i would
say windows
node because both of these are windows
only so that's fine i just give an
identifier saying that windows node
i would say this is a permanent agent i
will say okay
so if you see the name let me just copy
this name here
with the description number of executors
since it's a slave node and both of
these are running
on my system i'll keep the number of
executors as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just
clarify this since i have both my
my master is running on my c drive c
drive program files 86
or not 86 c colon program files
it is indeed 86. all right jenkins
so this is where my master is running so
i don't want the c drive what i'll do is
i'll use something called as a drive i
have another drive in my system
but please visualize this like you know
you're running this on a separate system
altogether
so i create a folder here called jenkins
node and this is where i'm going to
place my
or i'm going to provision my slave and
i'm going to run him from here
so this is the directory in which i'm
going to provision my
slave node so i'm going to copy this
here and that is the remote root
directory
of your particular agent or slave so i
just copied here
the label you know probably this is fine
for me
and usage how do you want to use this
guy
so i would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs
i will only build jobs with label
expressions that match this particular
node and so this is the label of this
node
so in order for somebody to kind of
delegate any task to them
they'll have to specify this particular
label so imagine this way
if i have a bunch of windows system i
name it as windows star
anything that says from windows i can
give a regular expression and say that
anything that matches windows run this
particular task there if i have some mac
machines
i name all these mac agents as a mac
star or something like that
and i can delegate all tasks you know
saying that start with
whatever starts with mac and this node
run the mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there
all right so launch method you know we
will use java web start because we're
going to
we we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good
directory i think nothing else is
required availability
yes we'll keep this agent yep online as
much as possible that sounds good
all right let me save this
all right i'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if i click on this node i get a bunch
of commands
along with an agent.jar so this is the
agent.jar that has to be taken down
to the other machine or the slave node
and from there i need to run this
along with a small security credential
so let me
copy this whole
[Music]
text here in my notepad
not bad plus plus is good for me
okay i copy this whole
path there i also want to download this
agent.jar
i would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server
so all the details that is required for
launching this agent.jar is found in
this
sorry for launching this agent it's
found this agent.jar so typically i need
to
take this jar file onto the other system
and then kind of run it from there so
i have this alien.jar i copy this or
whether i cut this
i come back to my folder my jenkins node
i paste it here
okay so now with this provisionagen.jar
and i need to use this
whole command ctrl a ctrl c
and then launch this particular agent so
let me
bring up a command prompt right here and
then launched it so i'm saying
in the same folder where there is
agent.jar i'm going to launch this a
particular agent java hyphen jar
agent.jar jnlp this is the url of my
server in case the server and client are
on different locations or different ips
you have to specify the ipad address all
this any way would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your
jenkins or the slave node
okay so
something ran and then you know it says
it's connected very well it seems to
connected very well so let me come back
to my
jenkins instance and see you know if
you're told you see
earlier this was not connected now let
me refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision
jenkins node and then i copied all the
credentials of the slave.jar along with
the launch code
and then took it to the other system and
kind of ran it from there
since i don't have another system i've
just got a separate directory in another
folder
another drive and i'm launching the
agent from here
as long as this particular agent is up
and running or this command prompt is up
and running
the agent would be connected so once i
close this the connection goes down
all right so successfully you've
launched this particular agent
now this would be the home directory of
this jenkins
node or the jenkins slave so any task
that i'm going to delegate to this
particular
slave would all be run here it'll create
a workspace right here
all right so good so let me just
come back and let me kind of put up a
new task here
i will say that you know delegate job is
good i say freestyle project
i'm going to create a very very simple
job here
i don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very
very
simple echo
relegated to the slave
negative two i don't like the word slave
delegate it to
agent put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am i going to ensure that
this particular job
runs on the agent or on the slave that
i've configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave
we give a label right so now i'm going
to put in
a job that will only match this
particular label
so i'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know windows label
run this job on that particular node so
we have only one node that's matching
this in a windows node
so this job will be delegated out there
so i save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this i just want to
demonstrate
how to kind of delegate it to an agent
so if you see this
it ran successfully and uh where is the
workspace
the workspace is right inside our
jenkins node it created a new workspace
delegated job it put in here so my old
or
my primary master job is in sql
program files under jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully
run very very simple but very very
powerful concept of master slave
configuration or distributed built in
jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
um we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff
now we don't want this configuration to
kind of go away
we want a very nice way of ensuring that
we back up all this configuration
and in case there is any failure
hardware crash or a machine crash
we would want to kind of restore from
the existing configuration that we kind
of backed up
so one quick way to do that would be or
one dirty way to do that would be just
you know take a complete backup of us
colon program files colon jenkins
directory because that's where our whole
jenkins configuration is present
but we don't want to do that let's use
some plugins for
taking up a backup so let me go to
manage jenkins
and click on available and let me search
for some back there are a bunch of
backup plugins
so i would recommend one of these
plugins that i specifically use
so this is the backup plugin so let me
go ahead and install this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin so let me come back to my
manage plugins stop this plugin is there
so hang on backup manager
so you will see this option once you
uninstall this plugin
so first time i can you know do a setup
i would say backup this particular
i'll give a folder uh this folder is
pertaining to the folder where i want
jks to backup some data
and i would say the format should be zip
format is good enough
let me give a name or a template or a
file name for my
you know backup this is good i want it
in verbose mode i don't want to shut on
my jenkins or should i shut it down
no okay one thing that you got to
remember is that whenever a backup
happens
if there are too many jobs that is
running on the server it can kind of
slow down your uh
jenkins instance because it's it's in
the process of copying a few of those
things
and the files are being changed at that
moment it's little bit problematic for
jenkins
so typically you backup your servers
only when there is very less load or
typically try to
you know bring it to a shutdown kind of
a state and then take a backup
all right so i'm gonna backup all these
things you know i don't want
to exclude anything else i want the
history i want the maven artifacts
possibly i don't want this guy i would
just say save
and then i would say back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps
and all the files that is required as a
part of
this is pretty fast but then if at all
you have too many things up on your
server for now we didn't have too many
things up on our server
but in case you had too many things to
kind of backup this may take a while
so let me just pause this recording and
get back to you once the
backup is complete so there you go the
backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users
and you know all that so all this is
kind of hidden down in this particular
zip file
so at any instance if at all i kind of
crash my system
for some instance or say hard disk
failure and i bring up a new instance of
jenkins
i can kind of use the backup plugin for
restoring this particular
configurations so how do i do that i
just come back to
my managing cans come back to
backup manager and i will say restore
that's an
or jenkins configuration that concludes
our tutorial on jenkins thank you for
stopping by and watching this video
hope it was useful for you and inspired
you to get your hands dirty with jenkins
and
play around with it for more learnings
please do visit us at www
www.simplylearn.com have a great day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here